♪ ♪
>> Laura: NOW,
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN DELIVERED
REMARKS AT A "BUILD BACK BETTER"
EVEN TODAY.
NOW, THE SPEECH WAS RIDDLED WITH
ALLIES THAT WILL GO UNCHECKED BY
THE MEDIA BUT ARE WORTH
DOCUMENTING HERE AS THE ECONOMY
SLIDES BACK TO THE 1970s.
LINE NUMBER ONE, BIDEN SAYS THE
INFLATION REPORT IS "GOOD NEWS
FOR AMERICA."
>> TODAY I AM PLEASED TO SHARE
MORE GOOD NEWS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE LATEST REPORT ON CONSUMER
PRICE SHOWS -- PRICES
SHOW -- THAT WE HAVE
EXPANDED -- EXCUSE ME, THE
EXPECTED EASING WE THOUGHT WAS
GOING TO COME HAS INCREASED,
THAT WE -- THAT WE HAVE SEEN A
GOOD MONTHLY REPORT.
>> Laura: OKAY.
WELL, REALITY, INFLATION ISN'T
JUST UP 5.4% ANNUALLY.
THE SPECIFIC SECTORS HURT
AMERICANS.
SINCE LAST YEAR, THE GAS PRICES
ARE UP 41.8%, USED CARS UP
41.7%, FOOD PRICES UP 5.4%, AND
ELECTRICITY UP 4%.
FURTHER, AVERAGE HOURLY WAGES,
THEY ARE NOT TRACKING WITH THESE
PRICE INCREASES.
THEY ARE ONLY UP 4% FROM A YEAR
AGO.
MEANING THE 5.4% INFLATION
INCREASE COMPLETELY WIPES OUT
ANY WAGE AGAIN.
MY NUMBER TWO, HE IS NOT
STANDING IN THE WAY OF OIL PRIC.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOTHING STANDS IN THE WAY OF OIL
PRICE DECLINES LEADING TO LOWER
PRICES FOR CONSUMERS.
WE ALSO MADE IT CLEAR TO OPAQUE
THAT THE PRODUCTION
CUTS MADE DURING THE PANDEMIC
SHOULD BE REVERSED AS THE GLOBAL
ECONOMIC -- ETHICAL ECONOMY
RECOVERS, IN ORDER TO LOWER
PRICES FOR CONSUMERS.
>> Laura: REALITY?
WELL, BIDEN STOOD IN THE WAY THE
OIL PRICE DECREASES STARTING ON
DAY ONE OF HIS PRESIDENCY WHEN
HE KILLED THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
ALL THE REGULATIONS THEY ARE
PUTTING ON DRILLING, DEFENDING
DRILLING LEASES ON FEDERAL
LANDS, AND NOW HE HAS BEEN
FORCED TO PLEAD WITH OPEC.
HOW EMBARRASSING.
"PLEASE BOOST OIL PRODUCTION,
SINCE GAS PRICES ARE STARTING TO
HURT ME POLITICALLY."
LINE NUMBER THREE, BIDEN SAYS HE
BOUGHT AN ECONOMY -- BROUGHT AN
ECONOMY BACK FROM, WELL,
BASICALLY IT WAS DEAD.
>> WE BROUGHT THIS ECONOMY BACK
FROM A COLD START, AND THERE IS
GOING TO BE -- THEY ARE GOING TO
BE SOME UPS AND DOWNS.
WE NEED TO MAKE THIS ECONOMY
WORK BETTER FOR WORKING FAMILIES
IN THE LONG RUN.
THESE CHALLENGES WERE WITH US
LONG BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
BEFORE I TOOK OFFICE.
>> Laura: OKAY, HERE'S THE
REALITY.
UNEMPLOYMENT PEAKED AT 14.8% IN
APRIL OF 2020.
ECONOMISTS THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO STAY HIGH FOR A LONG TIME,
BUT WHAT HAPPENED?
AND THE RED STATES REOPENED THE
ECONOMY, CAUSING UNLIMITED
PLUNGE DOWN TO 3.6% IN
JANUARY WHEN TRUMP LEFT OFFICE.
UNDER BIDEN, UNEMPLOYMENT HAS
ONLY FALLEN 0.9 POINTS.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC, MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME, REMEMBER, IT
WENT UP $5,000 DURING TERMS
PRESIDENCY, AND UNEMPLOYMENT IS
AT HISTORIC LOW